it is time for christmas
your daily sniff of the good news
scented candle i need a good news candle
we'll talk about you want some good news
me that's ross matthew
oh
thanks you know you got to spread the
good around a little bit that's what we
do here at the desk right drew i love
spread it spread it get in there
let's get to the news first up we've got
wedding bells for the barker kardashian
oh that's right it literally just
happened i love this
or did it
uh the cut reports after the grammys in
vegas um last weekend kourtney
kardashian and travis barker hit the
chapel as one does in vegas come on um
at 1 30 in the morning the love birds
got married by an elvis impersonator in
a true chef's kiss vegas style
um but there is rumor that maybe it's
not official and it was a
sort of a practice fun ceremony i don't
know maybe we'll find out on their show
i i don't know what this is but
i think congratulations to the happy
couple it sounds like a really fun night
of course i'm like did they do it for
the show is this a
not real or is it real i don't know i
hope it's real i hope so bad it's real
because i like them together as a couple
and i will say the kardashians and this
is no shade but they have had some
outlandish weddings in the past right
we've all watched it and so the fact
that they maybe did this like little
intimate thing i think is cute and the
reports were it was just the two of them
so but i think they probably filmed it
on their iphone right for the hulu show
well can they they have to like
contractually wouldn't you think
kourtney kardashian has texted uh
like something about a fun night tequila
no license
oh really she just put this out on
social media yes so the report now is
they did it but there was no
license no receipts so that's legit
means it didn't happen then yep i guess
so or it's not official at least well
fun night though totally
and uh i feel like they kind of give me
um
all the friskies you know
so i i like them and i we need a little
more friskiness in our lives exactly
bring it on bring it on
so good luck to them whatever
the case may be
all right flamingo alert
people reports a flamingo was spotted in
texas that's right fisherman david
foreman caught the bird on camera and it
turns out that this is flamingo number
492
a bird that's been on the run
since 2005 when it escaped a kansas zoo
wow apparently he has been living his
best life
in coastal texas
people have spotted him over the years
affectionately nicknaming him pink floyd
oh
and the good news is because of course i
had to ask he still remains free
yeah so
where will he go next
i don't know but like now i feel like
i'm whenever i'm going to have a day off
in life it's going to be a 492. yeah
you're just going to flee me go girl i
am
i and and and they put the anklet on
they came to the kansas zoo
when it was a baby but they didn't get
to clip its wings they didn't have time
before they took off
and uh and i think it's a great metaphor
don't clip the wings yeah flamingos
always freak me out a little bit why
because they stand on one leg and they
hide their hand a head in the sand like
what are you hiding girl what are you
hiding i don't trust you so does that go
for ostriches too yeah i don't trust
them either i don't i don't
well from pink to green news we've got a
little bit of green news for you
good transition
um
the new york times reports you know
those little plastic six packs rings
that are on like beer cans or soda
they'll say bye-bye to them because
they're gonna be history really yeah
coors light is the latest mega beer
brand
to get rid of them by 2025 they say
they're going to use all cardboard rings
eliminating 1.7 million pounds of
plastic per year and we've all heard
those stories about those rings in the
ocean so goodbye
goodbye
isn't that great news thank you
[Music]
you